you know it's wrong to take away the
power from the parents it's their
children not not the
government's children
it's our children
i think if you bring children into this
world then you should have a say in what
they learn they're trusting the the
educators
to
be fair
unbiased and truthful about what their
children should learn
i mean i think the biggest part starts
at home not in the school to begin with
it starts in the home the government has
a real interest in making certain that
people are
well informed and educated about their
civic responsibilities i homeschool
because i want to control what my kids
learn i think that
a lot of times
bad stuff happens at schools and bad
things are taught because
everybody has a different opinion
i think when they're more involved the
kids learn more i believe it's the
parents should have a say in their own
child's education i have a six years old
right now which is
i'm teaching her the diversity not about
the color they absolutely have to have
people involved
otherwise it's just not going to work
they need the reinforcement of the
parents and they need to consent to the
parents each child is individual and the
parents are the best judgment of their
children i'm responsible for my kids and
i want to instill in them my values
i don't think that's
up to other people